definitely the the girls in my class got
better grades than the boys in the class
so i think i had a closer relationship
with with a number of the guys in my
class just because both being guys that
helps to create something of a bond
right off the bat yeah and why that is I
don't know certainly I can say they're
there a number of my students a lot of
my students have kept in touch with and
they're probably equally split between
guys and girls and even in terms of the
former students who I look to bring out
bring on to the donorschoose.org team I
can think of a couple former male
students who I have in mind as people I
want to join the staff team at
donorschoose.org and and a couple female
students so an equal number but on yeah
I'm not a policy expert i wish i could
speak to sort of what's behind the the
guys getting not getting not doing as
well in school
you